[Applauso]
[Musica]
dove saremo Tra 5 anni quante volte
anche voi vi siete posti questa domanda
conversando amabilmente con i vostri
amici noi ci lo chiedevamo abbastanza
spesso prima di iniziare la nostra
avventura imprenditoriale ci chiedevamo
ci saremo restati all'estero o se
saremmo tornati in Italia
se saremmo stati sole o con una famiglia
Poi proprio quando abbiamo preso il
coraggio di provare a crearci un lavoro
che corrispondesse ai nostri valori
proprio il giorno in cui dovevamo
inaugurare il nostro e-commerce i
prodotti sostenibili L'Italia intera
ballo lockdown
la nostra città natale Bergamo e
l'epicentro europeo di una pandemia
globale che satura gli ospedali già
pieni di persone care l'umore non era
sicuramente quello con cui avremmo
voluto iniziare un nuovo percorso e così
decidiamo di creare un gruppo di
volontari che potesse aiutare le
farmacie a portare i farmaci alle
persone che non potevano e non dovevano
assolutamente uscire di casa
in quei giorni il futuro non esisteva
più il presente era così presente che
fare ogni congettura su quello che
sarebbe potuto succedere risultava
completamente inutile una perdita di
tempo e poi i giorni passano Come fanno
sempre del resto il futuro continua a
cambiare e assumo una forma
completamente inedita diversa da
qualsiasi cosa noi ci potrà ci potessimo
essere mai immaginate in questi due anni
siamo cambiati tanto fermarci ci ha
costretto a vedere costituita da un
altro punto di vista
fermarci ci ha costretto a porci delle
domande
sto bene
È questa la vita che voglio
è il lavoro giusto per me
è la strada giusta per me è normale che
queste domande siano passate nella
vostra testa in questi due anni ma noi
eravamo e siamo soltanto due persone che
volevano renderla sostenibilità un
argomento interessante o perlomeno Meno
noioso noi eravamo e siamo soltanto due
amiche che volevano lavorare con e per
una ragione senza seguire le classiche
regole del lavoro del produci produci e
produci
in questi due anni la natura ci ha dato
un grande insegnamento la forza
dell'adattamento Ognuno ha suo modo si è
adattato ed è andato avanti ma noi non
siamo più riusciti a fare delle
previsioni ce le chiedevano nella vita e
nel lavoro ma come si poteva prevedere
qualcosa davanti al crollo di ogni
certezza non riuscivamo a compilare
neanche uno di quei documenti che ci
veniva richiesto sulla crescita del
nostro progetto
dove saremo Tra cinque anni Ecco di
nuovo questa domanda nelle nostre vite
in realtà in questi due anni questa
domanda è diventata ancora più grande ma
noi un futuro tra cinque anni ce
l'avremo
non vogliamo spaventarvi vogliamo che
dopo questi minuti passate insieme voi
possiate guardare con speranza e
positività verso il futuro Ma è proprio
da qui che vogliamo partire in un ve lo
diciamo neanche con un tono di paura o
con quello di vittime che devono subire
le conseguenze di scelta altrui ve lo
diciamo con un potere Il potere della
consapevolezza
consapevoli dell'importanza di ogni
azione che facciamo nella nostra vita
consapevoli dell'importanza delle scelte
che prendiamo nella nostra quotidianità
consapevoli che come si svolgerà un
futuro Dipenderà solo da ognuno di noi
probabilmente nella vostra testa in
questo momento possono passare delle
idee che suonano come ma come può il
futuro dipendere da me se tutto è già
scritto se non sono assolutamente
d'accordo con le scelte che vengono
prese a livello globale se ancora oggi
vengono spesi miliardi in armi e ci sono
persone che muoiono di fame Ecco questo
è un altro potere il potere
dell'impotenza ci blocca ci fa
arrabbiare e ci fa sentire parte di un
ingranaggio che non siamo in grado di
cambiare i problemi sono troppo grandi
per persone piccole come noi ma la
volete sapere una verità
tutti siamo piccoli e Semplicemente
nessuno può fare niente da solo neanche
la persona che considerate più
importante può fare nulla da sola
Quando cominciamo a cambiare prospettiva
dalla sfera globale dal pianeta Terra
iniziamo a zoomare e torniamo vicino
vicino vicino torniamo alla strada che
ci porta a casa ogni giorno torniamo a
casa torniamo a noi stessi ci guardiamo
dentro prima di guardare fuori e ci
chiediamo c'è qualcosa che posso fare
per migliorare la mia vita c'è qualcosa
che posso cominciare a fare oggi per
trovarmi Esattamente tra cinque anni
dove voglio essere
noi due e magari anche qualcuno di voi
desideriamo un futuro più sostenibile
una realtà in cui la natura sia di nuovo
protagonista l'acqua sa potabile in
abbondanza e l'aria fresca e da
respirare a pieni polmoni
pensiamo di poter cambiare il mondo
Assolutamente no
pensavamo di poter cambiare noi stessi
fin da subito no da subito quello no
saranno due teste dure però ci siamo
dette che il mondo non cambiava se non
cominciavamo a cambiare noi stessi e
così abbiamo iniziato a farlo vedere le
cose in grande ostacolava i nostri
pensieri e così abbiamo iniziato da
qualcosa di piccolo Un prodotto che
avevo portato da un mio viaggio in
Messico è durato 4 anni Ma questa è
un'altra storia si tratta di uno shampoo
solido un prodotto ancora innovativo sul
mercato italiano e così dal trovare
soluzioni che potessero eliminare la
plastica dal bagno di ogni persona siamo
arrivati ad offrire soluzioni per
l'intera cucina e poi per l'intera casa
abbiamo deciso di supportare i piccoli
artigiani invece che grandi
multinazionali abbiamo deciso di
conoscere ogni fase del processo
produttivo dei nostri prodotti e sono
stati tutte delle scelte anche quella di
eliminare la plastica usa e getta dalla
nostra quotidianità o quella di cambiare
la nostra alimentazione in favore di una
Plant Based ma anche quella di scegliere
un fornitore di energia pulita o una
banca che fosse etica perché le scelte
sono importanti e si sommano e in cinque
anni il futuro può cambiare
Noi abbiamo iniziato questo viaggio in
due ad oggi siamo più di 50.000 persone
a credere in un futuro migliore
tra due e 50 mila ci sono state
tantissime cose in mezzo ci sono stati
più di 400 posti sociali ci sono stati
innumerevoli video della nostra
quotidianità arricchita dalla bellezza
della natura e ci sono stati altrettanti
innumerevoli video in cui raccoglievamo
i rifiuti di chi Purtroppo questa
bellezza ancora non l'ha del tutto
compresa ci sono stati interventi in
piazza interventi in contesti più
eleganti ci sono stati aziende che ci
hanno permesso di fare corsi di
sensibilizzazione a dipendenti che fino
a poche ore prima di conoscerci non
sapevano non pensavano assolutamente che
la sostenibilità avesse qualcosa a che
fare con loro ci sono state passeggiate
con più di 50 persone dai 4 ai 74 anni
per ripulire 5 km di campagna durante
una mattinata in cui il sole scioglieva
la neve
ci sono stati
ci sono stati degli eventi in cui
abbiamo proposto Solo cucina vegetale ma
Gourmet e abbiamo parlato e abbiamo
sentito le storie di persone ordinarie
che avevano storie di ispirazione
straordinarie e tutto questo per
dimostrare che si può fare senza
giudicare né voler insegnare nulla ma
semplicemente mostrando con curiosità
Come si può avere uno stile di vita più
sostenibile del resto è quello che noi
faremmo tutti i giorni con i nostri
amici durante un aperitivo
ispirare le persone a trovare la propria
strada perché make you greener sei tu
che decidi come diventare più verde
quando abbiamo saputo che eravamo
partecipato a questo evento non abbiamo
potuto far altro che chiedere alla
nostra Community In cosa le avessimo
ispirati Dopotutto se siamo qui oggi è
anche grazie a loro c'è chi ci ha detto
che ha smesso di buttare i mozziconi di
sigarette per terra e non so voi ma noi
è sembrato un traguardo incredibile
C'è chi ha cominciato a dilettarsi in
cucina con ricette anti spreco e chi ha
cominciato a comprare solo frutta e
verdura di stagione locale e poi c'è chi
è diventato addirittura vegetariano chi
ha avuto più consapevolezza di tutto
dell'importanza delle proprie azioni e
ancora chi ha iniziato a capire che non
serve un grande cambiamento radicale ma
piccole azioni durature nel tempo e
ancora chi sente di dare l'esempio e
finalmente sente di fare la differenza
E poi c'è chi dice che ha iniziato ad
apprezzare l'effetto farfalla voi lo
conoscete Beh Tanto per iniziare è il
nostro effetto preferito e quell'effetto
per cui piccoli cambiamenti nelle
condizioni iniziali riescono a generare
grandi cambiamenti in quelli finali e
quell'effetto per cui due amiche
cominciano a credere in un progetto che
prima non esisteva e fanno credere a uno
sconosciuto che le cose stiano cambiando
e ci sia speranza per il futuro
l'esempio pratico e concreto di altre
persone una narrazione concentrata sui
piccoli cambiamenti che riescono a
innescare grandi e incredibili
cambiamenti ci dà speranza e ci fa
credere che un futuro più sostenibile
dipende da ognuno di noi
l'effetto farfalla ci fa passare
dall'impotenza al potere individuale che
si trasforma in forza collettiva e
grazie a questa spinta che ci assumiamo
ogni giorno la responsabilità di credere
in un futuro migliore
ed è ancora più magico perché lo
facciamo insieme a più di 50.000
sconosciuti di cui sappiamo per certo di
avere solo una cosa in comune
l'amore per la nostra casa il pianeta
Terra un giorno una ragazza ci ha detto
che da quando ci segue Guarda molto di
più il cielo non è già questa una
ragione per credere in un futuro
migliore
Grazie di cuore
[Applauso]